imagine he had a universe which was a
googolplex meters across okay so big
universe then that's very big and if you
actually traveled far enough in that
universe you would start to see
repetitions you would start to see exact
copies of yourself
today we've got a Google at Google at
Google as in the website kind of not
spelt the same it's spelt G double o gol
10 to the power of 100 so imagine that
that's a one with a hundred zeros after
it
and it was solving it came about because
it was a is a guy called Kasner and he
was a mathematician he was also a very
famous in cosmology it wasn't him that
came up with the name he just thought of
a really big number he thought what's a
big number one with a hundred zeros and
he wants to sort of explain infinity and
he wants to come up with a very big
number there wasn't really big at all
compared to infinity and he actually has
his nephews nine-year-old nephew what's
a good name to call this number his
nephew came up with the air with the way
Google but it's quite a big number I
don't think it's that big a number but
it's quite a big number I mean to put it
into its perspective and you might ask
yourself well okay how many how many
grains of sand could you fit inside this
room okay do you think that's a lot
right that's going to be a lot of grains
of sand it's only about 50 billion not
that much so you might ask well let's
have something more dramatic how many
how many particles are there in the
universe okay now that's 10 to the 80 10
with a 1 with 8000 so many particles
there are in the universe so a googol is
bigger than that and you could ask
yourself okay well how many grains of
sand could I fit in the universe say the
universe was full of just grains of sand
how many grains of sand can I fit in the
universe and that would be about 10 to
the 90 cell one with 90 zeros after it
it's quite a big number but it but it's
not that big there's there's certainly
stuff that's a lot bigger than IQ
so you're saying it's not that big a
number and you're all these things that
we think of as big lot size of the
universe and atoms in the universe and
particles and even touching it something
must be it must be big well yeah okay
but I can think of something that is
bigger than it that's physical that you
can think of physically so if you take
the the smallest volume in the universe
something like which is a Planck volume
so it's basically a little cube that's
it's radius is a Planck length which is
10 to the minus 35 meters okay and you
see how many of them you can fit in the
observe
universe and you get about 10 to the 183
so that's a 1 with 183 zeroes after it
so that is bigger than a googol okay so
Google's aren't that impressive so we
can think of things that are bigger he
then thought well what's a bigger number
than a googol and for that he took 10
and raised it to this power the power of
a googol 10 to the 100 so this is taking
10 and x in it by 10 and 10 and 10 and
10 and 10 and x in it google amount of x
and this number is called a googolplex
we start writing down it at Googleplex
okay and let's suppose what we write on
a piece of paper here but let's suppose
we actually tried to write it down on on
particles so for each particle we're
going to write down zero so first
particle we write down as zero second
particle we write down to zero and we
carry on doing that on every particle in
the universe and we still would not be
able to write down a googolplex it's too
big a number and something else
remarkable about about the Googleplex so
this thing I find this astonishing
imagine you had a universe this sort of
emphasizes how big a googolplex is
imagining how the universe which was a
googolplex meters across okay so big
universe and some models of internal
inflation and things like that you do
get universes which could be as big as
this so we have a universe which is a
googolplex meters across then that's
very big and if you actually travelled
far enough in that universe you would
start to see repetitions you would start
to see exact copies of yourself now you
might think what the hell am I talking
about here ready but you know let's take
you very let's say let's ask how many
quantum states could describe the volume
that you occupy okay right the number of
quantum states that can occupy that
volume the total number is you can work
this out so something to do with entropy
and black holes and stuff like that but
you can work it out and it is 10
to the 10 to the 17 that's a number of
different quantum states different ways
that you could actually put together
that that volume of space so let's say
so that number is less than a googolplex
why so the space I mean could be me it
could be you it could be a dog could be
a very assume it could be anything could
be that all those particles are raised
in any number of different ways they
could particles might not even be there
but all those possible states given that
volume that you occupy the number that
you could they're not the number of
possible states you could have is 10 to
the 10 to the 7 see big number not as
big as a googolplex pretend to the
Google is equal to 10 to the 10 100 okay
so this number is clearly less than this
number okay so you occupy roughly about
a meter cubed of space there's that many
different possible states that you could
you could be in okay so if you go this
many meters away from yourself you know
you would start to expect to see
repetitions so that means if you're in a
universe which is so big because as big
as a googolplex meters across then
eventually you would start to see
repetitions of those sort of those
volumes at 1 meter cubed so just by
chance I'll run into another arrangement
of atoms that matches me exactly exactly
exactly matches you exactly and then you
know you go even bigger and you would
start to see sort of entire unit entire
observable universe is repeated so this
is truly remarkable Ganga if you went
far enough away in it in a googolplex in
universe and I think I think is it's
just just sort of emphasize how big that
number really is but the size of the
universe is is there 10 to the 26 meters
sort of all cubed that's the size of the
universe so this number is you know tiny
compared to that so there's probably not
another me in this universe probably not
but if we live in a universe which is a
googolplex across then that probably is